right now here it is Mark 12 here's the
argument I've never heard this
argument I've never heard this argument
before never no no no by the way if you
go to the description box you will see I
posted a series of Articles and
rebuttal addressing these points it's
there addressing these points so
whatever you hear from me you can then
read well here's the argument Jesus
taught to brother Jesus taught to
worship this handicap man why like this
alham Jesus Mark 12 29:30 from the new
King James
version Jesus answered them the first of
all the Commandments is here o Israel
the Lord Our God the Lord is one and you
shall love the Lord your God with all
your heart with all your soul with all
your mind and with all your strength
this is this is the first commandment
see alhamd Jesus brother ald Jesus Jesus
t
okay are you ready to now refute this
nonsense go to my description box I link
to several articles here's one of them
here's one of the articles that I link
to if the page Ops up according to
Deuteronomy 64 there is only one God one
Yahweh God Jesus himself quoted this in
Mark 12:29 to prove that God is one
since Jesus quotes this as one of the
greatest Commandments doesn't this prove
that he didn't believe in the TR in
trying God or in his divinity so that's
just one on Mark 12:29 here it is
description box and then you'll find
parts one and two to a series I wrote
called the binitarianism
1 and two I address Mark
12:29 and Mark 12 3537 so it's all there
alhamd Jesus brother so let's begin okay
number
one who denies that the Lord God is one
number one who denies that the Lord God
is
one nobody does but the argument is a
little more sophisticated they'll say
hold on the argument is not just that
the God is one but that Jesus
distinguished differentiated himself
from that Lord God so let's read the
rest of it all
right that's the
argument so watch here that's the
argument it's not only that the Lord God
is one but Jesus quoted this as
differentiating the one God from him
because he includes himself in that
confession hereo Israel the Lord Our God
the Lord is
one so Jesus is clearly not that one
Lord that one God oh really let's see so
here's the rest of the passage Mark
1231 to
34 and the second like it is this you
shall love your neighbor as yourself
there is no other commandment greater
than these now if you don't know the
context Jesus is asked what is the
greatest commandment and you see you see
what the Lord said so let's go into a
little spiritual meat because the point
of
this teaching isn't to tell you how many
gods there are the point of this
instruction is to tell you what is the
greatest command in joined upon
Believers so you want me to go in depth
right you want a Bible class right where
the Holy Spirit illuminates me and
through me illuminates you you don't
want just surface level
right you guys want me it's why you're
here right and I want to thank you let
me thank you let me I don't thank you
guys enough let me tell you why I thank
you for putting up with me because of
the love of Jesus you have because you
trust the Lord's working through me why
had it not been for you guys coming to
these sessions I wouldn't have an
opportunity to teach and by teaching you
I'm learning and being perfected because
the more you repeat something the more
you meditate the greater the depth of
understanding you'll be given so you are
a blessing to me and that as I share the
spirit is working through me to
illuminate me to go deeper and plunge
deeper with you so we're all
learning so I thank you for that and I
thank you for supporting me as well you
know who you are your orders with the
Lord all right first point I want you to
see is not all commandments are
equal not all commandments are
equal Jesus just said the greatest
Commandments are know that the Lord your
God is one and you must love him
unconditionally wholeheartedly more than
anything and love your neighbor as
yourself in other words not all
commandments are equal some Commandments
are more important and bring greater
judgment or greater blessing than others
did you learn that from here that's
Point number one the greatest well if
there's the greatest there's the least
and the Lord affirms that in Matthew
5:19 so number
one
prioritize now don't get me wrong I'm
not
saying that even the least commandment
and be ignored no every commandment must
be obeyed but some
Commandments bring greater judgment
responsibility and blessings than others
all commandments are important all
commandments must be observed and obeyed
all commandments are important but not
all commandments are equal in terms of
responsibility and blessing and here it
is Matthew
5:19 and to prove to you that a True
Believer loves Christ will do all he can
not only to obey the greatest
Commandments but the least here's
Matthew 5:19 look what our lord
said Matthew
5:19 whoever breaks one of the least of
these Commandments did you guys catch
it great and least some Commandments are
greater some are less whoever therefore
breaks one of the least of these
Commandments and teaches men so shall be
called least in the king of Heaven you
see that if you want to be high in the
Kingdom emphasize and Obey even the
least commandment even the least of
commandment teach others to obey the
least of the commandment and you'll be
great in the Kingdom so that tells you
not everyone has the same status in
heaven because some will be great in
heaven some will be least some
Commandments are great some are least
but if you want to be great in the
kingdom and have a high rank emphasize
even the least of The Commandments exort
people to obey even the least of The
Commandments and you will be great you
see how that
works now let me give you an example of
a great commandment and a least
commandment under the Mosaic law right
what would be a greater sin to commit
adultery or to eat
swine to commit adultery but both are
sin both are our sin right what would be
a greater
crime to murder and shed innocent blood
or to eat camel
meat to murder and shed innocent blood
both are sin but they're not equal in
terms of gravity punishment
responsibility see how that works that's
what the Lord is saying so what are the
greatest Commandments love the one God
and no other unconditionally and love
your neighbor as yourself and you know
why that's astonishing guys the the
wisdom of the Bible because it's God's
word and God is infinitely wise are you
aware that the Jews say there are about
613 Commandments and here's my challenge
to every one of you did you know that
every
commandment has to do with these two
Commandments every commandment has to do
with these two Commandments loving God
and loving neighbor as yourself because
every commandment
inails and explains how you are to love
your neighbor and how do you love God
every commandment deals with those two
I'm not lying when it says do not
dishonor the Sabbath that's you showing
love to God do not take the lord's name
in vain that's sh you showing love for
God do not covet your neighbor's wife
that's you loving your neighbor when you
find your neighbor's animal in a ditch
take it out that's you loving your
neighbor as yourself every single
commandment is simply an outline
or a specification or in-depth
explanation of how you show your love
for your neighbor and for God every one
of them that's why Jesus said love the
Lord your God with all your heart soul
mind and strength and your neighbor as
yourself the greatest commands because
everything else is a commentary on how
you go about loving your neighbor as
yourself and loving God more than
anything do not dishonor your parents
because not only they your parents
they're your
neighbor see how that
works I'm not exaggerating go look at
the Commandments either it's a
commandment showing how you are to love
God or neighbor if I love God then I
won't violate the Sabbath if I love God
I won't worship God's and goddesses if I
love God I will not take his name in
vain if I love my neighbor as my myself
I won't covet his car or his house or
his wife or his status or his
Fame
right that's why the law is summed up in
these two Commandments the law is summed
up in these two
Commandments everyone got
it do you understand the 613
Commandments and don't take my work for
go look it up everything has to do with
loving your neighbor as yourself so this
is what you're going to do for your
neighbor and this is what you won't do
if you love him as yourself this is what
you're going to do for God and this is
what you won't do if you love God more
than
anything now let me give you another
example because it's relevant to people
today who struggle I know a lot of
people strugg and listen let me be
honest let me give you an example of
some sins being greater than others if
you ever read Deuteronomy
2213 to30 Deuteronomy 2213 to30
there God
prescribes specific punishments for
specific sexual
sins are you aware that a man being
caught having sex with a woman who's not
engaged or married that man is not
killed that woman is not killed you know
what their punishment
is and I want to tie it in tie it in
with today because that's the struggle
listen Brethren my prayer is if God
wants me to be sing like Paul he helps
me not to burn that's a struggle I'm
confessing so pray for me for Purity I
never act upon it never touch a woman
unless I'm married and if I'm not
married fight the good fight until the
Lord summons me some I've given that
gift if God wants me to celebrated
Hallelujah will be done I'm content
right
anyway do you know what the punishment
is if a man has sex with a woman that's
betroth married and he's married they
are to be put to death stoned if a man
rapes a woman he is to be killed and the
woman spared but did you know that in
Deuteronomy the sin for a man having sex
with a woman who's not married or
engaged and he's not married is that
that man must now marry her and can
never divorce her he does not have the
choice of
divorce did you know that that's Exodus
226 to 17 Deuteronomy 22 2829 now the
father can say well I don't want you to
be husband and then he'll pay a hefty
doy a bridal price and they'll consider
it a divorce but the man can't do it if
a man is caught sleeping with a woman he
is now bound to her until he
dies so notice what is a greater sexual
sin adultery or
fornication adultery you die fornication
your punishment is you have to live with
a nagging wife the rest of your days
you see that so what's what's say worse
crime or sin adultery or fornication
specifically Deuteronomy 22 28-29 and
exodus 2216 to
so adultery or fornication they're both
sin but one brings death you stoned
without Mercy the other brings a
lifelong prison sentence
a lifelong prison
sentence where the man is now stuck with
the woman and he's in prison for the
rest of his
life so you see how Ser serious sexual
intimacy is God designed sexual
intimacy between a husband and a wife
life in holy matrimony not before
marriage and not check up with multiple
partners First Corinthians 7 verses 1
and5 States 1 Corinthians 7 veres 1 and5
States if you burn seek a wife or a
husband that's what Paul says if you
haven't been given the gift of celibacy
find you a wife or find you a husband
but until then endure there is no sex
before marriage I know it's hard I know
many of us have F fallen and failed but
there is confession repentance
restoration but it has to be true
repentance meaning you turn back and
don't do it
again Focus now with me because I want
to make a point statistics confirm what
the Bible says don't take my word for it
even secular
humanistic studies studies done by
secularists who are humanists who are
atheists who don't care about God
Studies have proven this I'm not making
it up see medical
facts science is catching up to the
Bible because God designed you and knows
what's best for
you he knows what's best for you and he
knows what's not best for you the
designer of the body knows what's best
for the body Studies have shown this is
a fact a man did a study where he
examined men and women who are sexually
active and he found the more sexual
partners a person has the greater the
likelihood that person will be divorced
several times and cannot stay in a
committed
marriage indefinitely Studies have shown
the more you're intimate with multiple
partners the greater likelihood you will
fail in marriage after marriage you'll
have a higher divorce rate and it'll be
harder for you to stay in a healthy
lasting marriage
so keep that in mind and how does it
relate to Jesus there are greater
Commandments and lesser Commandments
some are great some are less all are
important and you must obey all of
them you must obey all of
them okay you must obey all of them from
the least to the greatest but a
commandment that's greater brings
greater blessing and or judgment and
responsib possibility